[Musique]
alors dans les salles cette semaine
aussi 17 plusieurs propositions dont une
à noter à partir du 15 janvier le film
événement de sam mendes 1917 qui traite
de la première guerre mondiale donc film
à voir dans une salle à partir du 15
janvier
[Musique]
et ça ici
et aussi le festival télérama dix films
à l'affiché
je vais simplement citer les titres le
très réussi film de tarantino à tous les
films sont en version originale je
précise once upon a time in hollywood le
film de la dgi qui est formidable qui
est sélectionné pour les oscars les
misérables le très beau film de céline
sciamma portrait de la jeune fille en
feu douleur et gloire le dernier
almodovar martin eden de pietro marcello
qu'on n'a jamais passé au ciné 7 ainsi
que une grande fille de contenir bas la
golf est si belle de guillaume
giovanetti une programmation pour les
enfants la fameuse invention des ours en
sicile et deux avant-premières la bonne
épouse et la fille aux bracelets ce
week-end aussi les sept
[Musique]